يدرك الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان ان
الانتخابات القادمه هي الاصعب ورغم انه لم
يهزم بانتخاباته من قبل لكنه للمره الاولى
يواجه معارضه متحده بهذا الشكل لذلك اراد
تقويه تحالف الشعب الذي يقوده باحزاب
جديده لكسب مزيد من الاصوات
تاسست تحالف الشعب رسميا عام 2018 بين حزب
العداله والتنميه وحزب الحركه القوميه
وحزب الاتحاد الكبير او الوحده الكبرى
وسعي لتعزيز موقف التحالف في الانتخابات
القادمه استطاع اردوغان كسبه تاييد حزب
الرفاه الجديد بقياده نجد رئيس الوزراء
الاسبق نجم الدين ايربكان وحزب الدعوه
الحره المعروف اختصارا بهدى بار وحزب
اليسار الديمقراطي بعض استطلاعات الراي
رجحت فقدان التحالف الاغلبيه في البرلمان
لكن حزب العداله والتنميه الحاكم الذي
يقود التحالف واثق من الفوز اكبر خلال 21
عاما من حكم العداله والتنميه تنعمت تركيا
بكثير من الانجازات الماثله للعيان لا نرى
اي تهديد حول فوزنا في الانتخابات القادمه
استطلاعات الراي مهمه من ناحيه التن
الاحصائي لكن الواقع الفعلي يظهر ملامح
فوزنا المحقق
تحالف رئيس الوزراء الاسبق بولينت اجاويد
في عام
1974 مع نجم الدين ايربكان وشكل معا حكومه
ائتلافيه اجاويد كان يراس حينها حزب الشعب
الجمهوري العلماني واربكان حزب السلامه
الوطني الاسلامي فيما بعد اسس اجاويد حزب
اليسار الديمقراطي وانشق عن حزب الفضيله
الذي اسسه ايرباكان حزب العداله والتنميه
مجددا في هذه الانتخابات يلتقي الجيل
الجديد من ذاك التحالف القديم ضمن تحالف
الشعب التوجهات الايديولوجيه متباعده لكن
المصلحه الانتخابيه واحده
تقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات